el objetivo de este vídeo es explorar
algunos conceptos sus fórmulas que
podrían encontrarse típicamente en las
clases de física tradicionales pero lo
más importante es que quiero que vean
que en realidad son ideas de sentido
común vamos a querer comenzar con un
ejemplo sencillo y para efectos de este
vídeo vamos a acordar que si se ve una
cantidad positiva
esto implica que vamos a estar
dirigiéndonos vamos a tener un sentido
hacia la derecha
y de igual manera si tenemos una
cantidad negativa esto implica que vamos
hacia la izquierda
esto es para simplificar un poco nuestra
notación de manera que no tenga que
poner la virtud la direccción
explícitamente al yo poner una cantidad
si se ve que es una cantidad positiva
estoy indicando la dirección además de
la magnitud de ese vector
entonces vamos a imaginar que tengo una
velocidad inicial
igual a 5 metros por segundo es una
cantidad positiva entonces implica que
son 5 metros por segundo a la derecha
y además tengo una aceleración constante
d
2 metros por segundo cuadrado al ser de
nuevo una cantidad positiva estamos
implicando que esta aceleración está
siendo se está dirigiendo hacia la
derecha
y vamos también a establecer que esta
velocidad y esta aceleración constante
va a durar
unos cuatro segundos así que el cambio
en el tiempo va a ser cuatro segundos
y lo que yo quiero saber es qué tan
lejos voy a llegar y cuál será mi
velocidad después de estos cuatro
segundos vamos a resolver primero lo que
es la velocidad final y vamos a hacer un
pequeño diagrama aquí
esta es
eje de la velocidad
velocidad
y este otro eje
es donde voy a indicar mi tiempo
entonces lo que me indica el problema es
que bueno mi velocidad inicial no sea en
el tiempo cero mi velocidad inicial
velocidad inicial
es igual a 5 metros sobre segundo
después de 1 2 3 4 segundos
lo que quiero saber es cuál va a ser mi
velocidad final bueno entonces tenemos
que iniciamos en el en cinco metros por
segundo al primer segundo que ocurra
bueno tengo una aceleración constante de
dos metros por segundo de manera que en
el primer segundo mi velocidad va a ser
de siete metros por segundo entonces más
o menos
mi gráfica o mi punto estaría más solos
por acá
si yo tomo esto y como es una velocidad
constante pues va a ser una línea recta
pero no mi aceleración es constante voy
a tener una línea recta bueno más o
menos recta así de esta forma de manera
que lo que yo quiero encontrar es cuando
llegue a o hayan pasado estos cuatro
segundos
manteniendo esta aceleración constante
quiero conocer
aquí cuál va a ser mi velocidad final
vamos a resolver esto usando variables y
usan los números concretos
entonces bueno aquí comienzo desde esta
parte aquí tengo mi velocidad inicial y
sé que cada dos metros cada from cada
segundo
mi velocidad se va a incrementar dos
metros por segundo
entonces qué es lo que puedo hacer pues
puedo indicar que mi velocidad inicial
velocidad inicial
mi cambio o mi desplazamiento en el
tiempo pero me cambiara el tiempo que
vienen siendo estos
cuatro segundos del tate
si yo multiplico esta vuelta t
por lo que es mi aceleración constante
entonces voy a encontrar el valor
multiplicado por mi aceleración
constante
esto me va a dar como resultado
lo que es mi velocidad final
entonces bueno si yo estoy en este punto
de la gráfica y multiplicó la duración
del tiempo por la pendiente de esta
línea entonces voy a obtener mi
velocidad final poniendo esto en números
tenemos que mi velocidad inicial es de 5
metros sobre segundo mi
cambio en el tiempo es de 4 segundos y
esto lo multiplicó por mi aceleración
que es de 2 metros sobre segundo al
cuadrado este segundo se va con uno de
los segundos de aquí abajo
y voy a tener
entonces cinco metros sobre segundo más
4 x 2
8 metros sobre segundo y si sumo esto
entonces voy a tener
mi velocidad final que es de 13 metros
sobre segundo esta es mi velocidad final
aquí sería este valor entonces serían 13
metros sobre el segundo velocidad final
igual a esto
entonces bueno vamos a hacer una pausa
aquí y vamos a pensar al respecto y
espero que esto sea algo intuitivo para
ustedes iniciamos con una velocidad de 5
metros por segundo cada segundo aumenta
esta velocidad de 2 metros por segundo
entonces al primer segundo quedamos con
7 metros la velocidad el segundo 2
nuestra velocidad es de 7 + 29 metros
sobre segundo al tercero
nuestra velocidad viene siendo bueno que
aquí la gráfica no está muy exacta pero
bueno estos son espacios regulares
serían 11 metros por segundo y al cuarto
segundo pues bueno es nuestro valor de
13 así que bueno esta fórmula tiene
sentido nos resultado es de 13 metros
por segundo así que
esta podemos
y resumir esta fórmula
de esta manera o bueno a esta fórmula de
hecho así tal cual como queda pues es
una fórmula que ustedes se encuentran
típicamente es una de las fórmulas más
conocidas en física básica la velocidad
final es igual a la velocidad inicial
más el cambio en el tiempo por la
aceleración en el caso de que la
aceleración sea constante entonces
pueden ver que esto no es algo inventado
es algo que viene de un razonamiento que
tiene bastante sentido común y bueno
pues de aquí viene esta fórmula ahora lo
que yo también quiero saber es cuál es
la distancia que he recorrido durante
este tiempo con esta aceleración
constante
como cálculo esto bueno del vídeo
anterior vimos que este la distancia
recorrida es el área bajo esta curva voy
a remarcar la el área a calcular que
viene siendo esta forma así como que un
poco extraña
el área dentro de ésta
figura es la cantidad de la distancia
recorrida
durante este tiempo
porque uno voy a calcular esta área
bueno pues vamos a usar este nuestros
conceptos de geometría básica vamos a
descomponer esto en dos figuras que pues
nos van a ser bastante fáciles de
calcular su área vamos a descomponer
aquí un rectángulo el área de un
rectángulo pues es muy sencilla de
calcular y aquí tenemos un triángulo que
también calcular el área de este
triángulo pues no es una edad complicada
esta parte de aquí esta área del
rectángulo
viene siendo
qué tan lejos llegamos sin acelerar
esto es sin acelerar que tanto
hubiéramos recorrido si nos hubiéramos
mantenido 4 segundos a 5 metros por
segundo
sin acelerar
y esta otra
área de aquí de este triángulo es que
tanto a distancia extra recorrimos por
la aceleración
así que bueno vamos entonces a hacer
este cálculo tenemos que al menos en
esta parte del rectángulo nuestra base
son 4 segundos
estos son 5 entonces 5 por 4
los metros por segundo se anulan con los
segundos de esta del tiempo y nos queda
que aquí son 20 metros los que
recorrimos sin tener que acelerar ahora
como calculamos esta parte de la
aceleración bueno
tenemos que esta parte es mi velocidad
final que fue igual a 13
metros sobre segundos y esta parte viene
siendo pues mi velocidad inicial no
olvidemos que siguen siendo vectores y
como son valores positivos son hacia la
derecha que es de 5 metros sobre segundo
entonces esta distancia
es ahí bueno
esta distancia es la diferencia de estas
dos cantidades que vienen siendo
13 menos 5 es igual a 8 metros sobre
segundo es lo que mide esta esta parte
nada más
esto lo multiplicó por una base que
vienen siendo cuatro segundos y la voy a
dividir a la mitad porque es la mitad de
este rectángulo
entonces como me queda
tengo que es mío
área del triángulo vamos a ponerla en
color vamos a mantener este color mi
área de este triángulo es igual a la
mitad de mi base que son 4 segundos por
la altura que son 8 metros por segundo
estos se anulan 8 por 4
es igual a 32 la mitad de 32 es igual a
16 metros entonces aquí son 16 metros
que recorrimos gracias a la cura de
aceleración constante
ahora lo que quiero hacer a mano si
queremos ver el total la distancia total
vamos a tomar otro color
mi desplazamiento porque estamos
hablando de directores va a ser igual a
la suma de estas dos áreas entonces va a
ser igual
a mis 20 metros
+ 16 me lo pongo en otro color para que
se vea de dónde salió más 16 metros de
la parte de aceleración
y vamos a ser consistentes con los
colores
20 metros porque esta es la parte de
verde 20 metros y los 16 metros es la
parte de la aceleración total que nos
queda un desplazamiento total de 36
metros este es nuestro resultado y ahora
vamos a realizar estos mismos cálculos
pero usando variables los que no nos va
a llevar a otra fórmula muy conocida
entonces quedamos que el área del
rectángulo vamos a hacer de nuevo el 20
el verde de color de este rectángulo y
ahora de este rectángulo es la
e
ok vamos a
cambiar colores así que disculpen que
estoy un poco
confundiendo los colores que tenemos que
usar pero bueno esta parte el área del
rectángulo
smith de diferencia o cambio en el
tiempo
x la altura que en este caso es min
velocidad inicial
esta parte es el área del
rectángulo que lo pongo aquí en verde es
esta parte ya esto le voy a sumar
lo que es el área de este triángulo que
quedamos que es la mitad
de igual el mismo cambio en el tiempo
del tate
multiplicado por su altura que en este
caso es la velocidad final menos la
velocidad inicial
entonces en este caso esto está
multiplicado por la velocidad final
menos
la velocidad inicial
y esto resulta ser pues la distancia
recorrida o el desplazamiento
vamos a seguir simplificando esta
fórmula de manera que nos quede algo un
poquito más breve entonces bueno tenemos
que como aunque antes de comentar lo que
me ponga a hacer este la simplificación
esta parte es el área de este triángulo
así que vamos a sacar el desplazamiento
en el tiempo como un elemento común a
ambos términos y esto lo voy a
multiplicar por mi velocidad inicial
más
la mitad
de esta que es mi velocidad final
menos
la mitad
de mi velocidad inicial
como más que más lo podemos simplificar
bueno tengo aquí mi velocidad inicial y
aquí menos la mitad de esta velocidad
inicial algo menos una mitad de ese
mismo algo pues nos va a quedar una
mitad normal y está entonces
nos queda
el cambio en el tiempo
un medio
de la velocidad inicial
más
un medio de la velocidad final
este medio lo podemos sacar de manera
que
tenemos
el cambio del tiempo
post
la mitad de
la velocidad inicial
más
la velocidad final
y pues finalmente esto que viene siendo
esta parte viene siendo el promedio de
la velocidad final y la velocidad
inicial esto entonces lo podemos
determinar o definir como la velocidad
promedio
hay que tener mucho cuidado
porque sólo podemos hablar o calcular o
usar esto como velocidad promedio cuando
tenemos una aceleración constante si la
aceleración fuera variable y el lugar
esto será una línea fuera una curva o
algo diferente entonces ya no podemos
usar esto ya no podemos hacer este
cálculo y finalmente ahora tenemos la
fórmula de la distancia que es igual a
el cambio en el tiempo por la mitad de
la velocidad
inicial más la velocidad final y esta es
otra fórmula muy conocida del cálculo de
la distancia desplazamiento
y bueno también para que vean que esto
tiene así que una razón lógica
este sentido común de dónde viene esta
fórmula para que no tenga necesariamente
que memorizar las y no la puedan deducir
así que en este caso pues bueno como
tenemos una aceleración constante
podemos resolver esto sacando la
velocidad promedio
que es igual a la mitad de la velocidad
final o la velocidad inicial en el orden
que quiera que es 13 metros por segundo
más 5 metros por segundo es igual a
18 entre 2 es igual a 9 metros por
segundo este es mi velocidad promedio
que vendría siendo más o menos a esta
altura y al usarla al multiplicar la o
usarla en esta parte la multiplicó por 4
segundos de manera que mi distancia es
igual a 4 por 9
36 metros y así llegamos al mismo
resultado que hicimos este por mes este
otro cálculo